the Joe Rogan experience you mentioned
corporates did you do any no no thank
you baby Jesus I did a gig at the cellar
this guy showed up and he goes I like
your stuff you're edgy you're raw come
to my country club come roast my country
club I was like oh great so he's like he
gave me a sheet of like all his
employees and all their dirt and he's
like really zing um really make it
vicious they always say vicious and I
show up and it's like Mercedes and you
know Benz is everywhere in Maseratis and
I'm like oh [ __ ] white tablecloths like
go up and I do the mic tap hey everybody
I'm gonna do some comedy and they go
he's gonna roast everybody sit back he's
gonna cigar in a suit and I go hey Bill
and Bill stands up when I go we all know
you're on coke we've seen it and feels
like what his wife's like oh my god
you're supposed to be clean and I'm like
oh well that didn't go well hey Jeff
Jeff we all know you're cheating on your
wife and she's like I knew it you know
and the kids are crying and you know Rob
we all know you're gay just come out
already and this is all the [ __ ] he gave
me and the place you know the place is
in in a brouhaha and I [ __ ] the guy
came back he's like get the hell out of
here so that was tough true story I
would imagine you would have
double-checked I just used what he gave
me this is all I knew seemed so
ridiculous that guys know did you ever
communicate with him after he was
furious furious he was pissed at me he's
like what happened I'm like what what
happened I did the [ __ ] you gave me you
said be vicious hate cuz he's like I
thought you make it funny I'm like I
just said the [ __ ] I made jokes but I
still had the dirt oh it was back try to
do a couple you know jokes after about
taxis and and peanut butter but it
didn't fly nothing no they were they
were just yelling at each other the
whole thing was ruined a rules me party
I got paid I had a bite with the guy
really and it was a solid check I might
say nice chunk of change
[Applause]